imaginez que vous allez à la pêche dans
un lac avec enfilez votre objectif n'est
pas d'attraper n'importe quel poisson
mais le poisson le plus rapide du lac ou
peut-être celle qui a le plus longue
nageoire ou un regard méchant mais y en
a quand seuls poissons dans le lac comme
celui recherché parmi des dizaines de
milliers d'autres poissons qui lui
ressemble
en plus les poissons mesure en centièmes
de millimètre et un talent le lac
quelques centimètres est ce que nous
pouvons faire est ce que nous avons les
outils technologiques qui nous permet de
faire cette pêche
évidemment je ne suis pas ici pour
parler de pêche sportive mais plutôt de
recherche biomédicale pourquoi parce
qu'il ya plusieurs processus biologiques
plusieurs maladies y compris le cancer
ou une seule cellule responsable
d'énormes changements dans les
organismes et donc l'identification et
la capture de ces cellules est très
importante pour comprendre les processus
et faire avancer la recherche
l'objectif de mon laboratoire parmi
plusieurs autres c'est de développer les
technologies qui nous permet de capturer
ces cellules et en plus nous voulons que
ces technologies soient faciles à mettre
à l'oeuvre et peu coûteuses les humains
on comprend et en le monde le perçoit
surtout à travers nos yeux et c'est
sûrement là viciant le sens de plus en
portant par contre pour la pêche
microscopique le pouvoir de notre vision
elle n'est pas assez n'est pas suffisant
il faut faire un pas au delà de ce que
l'évolution nous a donné et c'est pas
nous l'avons fait il ya 400 ans que nous
avons développé les technologies qui
nous permet d'observer des énormes et
objets à distance sidérale comme les
galaxies les étoiles les planètes mais
aussi les détails minuscules qui
composent la nature ou les cellules le
molécules les attend les héros de
l'astronomie sont rentrés dans
l'histoire et le nom de galilée notant
sont connues de toute l'humanité
par contre pour la microscopie
l'instrument du noun besoin pour la
pêche
zéro ne jouissent pas de la même
popularité
en fait on reconnaît de ea compte dans
l'histoire de la microscopie
le premier sera brook qui a publié en
1665 un livre appelé mikrograph iec été
un succès et victor yale où nous a
révélé un monde complètement en colombie
d'une part il nous montre de détails
incroyables des objets du quotidien
comme les aiguilles à coudre de lames de
rasoir des cheveux des plumes nous
décrit par la première fois une anatomie
minutieuse des des insectes y compris
les yeux composé pour la première fois
mais plus important que ça c'est lui qui
nous montre que les tissus biologiques
sont constitués des cellules en fait
c'est lui qui les noms comme sa cellule
le deuxième de nos héros c'est anthony
van loo il faut un marchand danois des
grands succès vendeur de tissus sans
aucune expérience académique qui dans
son livre est un artisan verrier qui
poli à la main des centaines de
minuscules antilles avec lesquels il
fait ses observations de routine
carrière d'une cinquantaine d'heures
parmi ses découvertes
il faut nommer les spermatozoïdes les
bactéries des protozoaires des cellules
rouges les capillaires la fatigue c'est
lui qui décrit le cycle de vie entier
des insectes incluant le fait qu'ils
déposent de surf que ce moment là les
insectes est supposé d'être générés de
façon spontanée et plusieurs de cette
découverte représente des vrais points
de rupture dans notre compréhension de
la vie de la maladie et de la mort donc
à quel point est-ce que les avancées en
microscopie sont aujourd'hui est ce que
nous pouvons ici on pense par exemple au
milieu des transports du xviiie siècle
avec les avions les trains les
automobiles est ce qu'on peut faire en
parallèle avec la technologie
microscopique d'aujourd'hui il faudrait
vous considérez moi je voudrais
mentionner trois éléments d'une part je
sais pas si vous êtes d'accord avec moi
mais les héros de la microscopie surtout
cook est un artiste un énorme calibre
ils parviennent avec ses illustrations à
transmettre la fascination qu'il a
sûrement ressenti au moment de poser les
yeux sur ces instruments
deuxièmement je voudrais mentionner la
l'instrumentation
aujourd'hui il y en a pas d'artisans qui
fabrique des microscopes d'une telle
beauté qui moi je mettrais dans une
vitrine dans une partie spéciale de mon
salon et troisièmement il faut dire que
il ya des lois de la nature qui impose
des limites au nombre de fois que nous
pouvons augmenter la taille d'une image
pour continuellement révélé de nouveaux
détails dans notre champion ce qui fait
que oui nous avons gagné beaucoup en
qualité d'image un peu en résolution
mais ultimement nous ont probablement le
niveau de détail ou presque que nos
héros de la microscopie
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est
c'est assez avec le microscope optique
courant pour fait faire la pêche
microscopique ses côtés un peu artiste
et que nous fait penser aux méfaits
passés à la peinture pourquoi parce que
si on pourriez colorier le poisson que
nous cherchons s'adonnèrent et du
contraste et après ça facilitera
énormément sa capture est en fait la
peinture cellulaire ça existe et les
scientifiques qui l'ont développé sont
des personnages très importante dans
l'histoire de la science les normes
comme gold j aime ça où il écrivit à la
tête
pourquoi parce que les cellules sont
pour la plupart transparente dans cette
coloration du contraste qui facilite
énormément déjà les trouvez donc avec
cette coloration a été capable de
découvrir du bar qu'ils ont une énorme
variabilité des formes et cette forme
est corrélé avec la fonction dans les
organismes
on a aussi été capable de découvrir que
ils sont des sous divisions internes
l'équivalent des organes de notre corps
nous savons peinture et ou colorés des
cellules des molécules uniques
nous avons contrôlé le moment auquel ses
colorations sont activés nous avons
modifié
les organismes pour qu'ils produisent
eux-mêmes leur coloration est donc cette
coloration est en fait la clé de la
microscopie moderne et oui nous savons
je dirais une fusée interplanétaire à
comparaison du possibilités du passé en
termes de coloration le seul bémol que
tout ça pour notre poisson rapide c'est
que la vitesse n'est pas une critique
caractéristiques biochimiques et
poussines état de coloration sont conçus
en fonction de la biochimie des
molécules qu'ils doivent perdre et donc
pour l'identification de ces poissons
nous avons toujours besoin de notre
vision et d'une brosse pour pouvoir
colorier avec notre brosse le poisson
rapide et c'est ça ce que mon
laboratoire fait nous avons développé
une brosse pour peinturer des cellules
cette brosse est une grosse laser
pourquoi lazare parce qu'on peut faire
ça pour est extrêmement fine est à la
fois précises pour peinturer une seule
cellule et donc les premiers essais de
notre technologie nous avons fait ça sur
les surfaces des horaires qui sont plus
simples que la surface cellulaire
est-ce que je vous montre ici sont aux
premières images où on utiliser la
brosse pour reproduire des photographies
et des oeuvres d'art très bien connu
pour que vous ayez une idée
ces échantillons ce miniature auprès
d'art ont l'équivalent du diamètre d'un
cheveu
donc il vous faut absolument un
microscope pour regarder ses oeuvres
d'art une fake curieux de la première
image c'est qu'en fait l'auteur original
le néerlandais johannes vermeer était un
voisin est un ferment un ami devant lui
ou un fou que notre héros de la
microscopie à mon avis les deux dans
leurs domaines respectifs devraient
champions maîtres de la lumière et de
notre perception l'étape suivante de
notre travail était de tester cette
technologie sur des surfaces cellulaire
et laon avec la brosse on a colorié
juste la cellule au centre de façon
d'avoir en passant rouge dans un lac
plein c'est le vin
et pour vous montrer que ce n'est pas
une cellule par hasard qui est devenu
colorier mais la cellule que nous
voulions coloré l'image qui suit c'est
un lac rempli de cellules dans chaque
cercle grise est une cellule où on a
déplacé notre pinceau pour générer
l'image que je vous montre
et encore une fois il vous faut un
microscope pour observer cette micro
scope l'avantagent de cette peinture ce
que les technologies qui permet de
séparer les cellules en fonction de leur
couleur ça existe mais ils ont optimisé
pour la situation dans lequel le nombre
de cellules colorier versus non colorier
se ressemblent dans notre cas nous
allons avoir en poissons colorés dans
des dizaines de milliers qui ne le sent
pas et plus ça nous oblige à contrôler
la couleur de chacun des cellules ce qui
rend la tâche inefficace dans c'est pour
ça que la deuxième version
nous allons nous avons remplacé la
peinture pour une colle de façon que les
cellules les poissons peinture et avec
notre bros reste collé au fond du lac et
que quand on videra le lac
seuls les poissons d'une santé reste
restera prix pour notre technologie
donc ce que vous voyez ici c'est encore
une fois en laque plein de cellules
chaque cercle bleu maintenant est une
cellule
nous avons illuminé avec la brosse laser
les continents mais pas les océans un
cas nous avons vidé l'or juste les
poissons colorés au continent reste
adhérer au fond du lac
et encore une fois pour observer cette
planète cette fois il vous faut un
microscope
la troisième version de la technologie
c'est celle qui se ressemblent le plus
de l'analogie du filet de pêche dans ce
cas ci nous allons remplacer la pente la
colle cette fois pour une espèce de
plaquages métallique en fait de
minuscules billes métalliques qui sont
avérées à la peau de poisson de façon
qu'avec un aimant on devrait pouvoir le
péché donc oui ce sera un vrai lac on
aurait besoin d'un lac dans les marges
gigantesque mais dans notre lac
miniature léman qui nous avait collé à
la porte de votre réfrigérateur suffit
pour pêcher uniquement
poissons que nous avons colorier avec
l'autre laser tandis que les restes de
dizaines de milliers continue à nager
tranquillement au p4 qu'on peut capturer
le banc durant les quatre dernières
siècle développement le centre de notre
attention se déplacer notre regard et
notre fascination ont cédé la place aux
méthodes qui relèvent de la biologie
moléculaire et de la biochimie ou notre
vision à un rôle mineur cependant ces
deux langues liste de processus où une
cellule unique est importante relève
surtout de notre capacité à apprécier la
vitesse le mouvement et la forme et pour
ça nos yeux jaunes grand rôle dans
grande importance notre travail consiste
à développer les technologies qui
renforce la puissance de nos yeux merci
[Applaudissements]